how's Cobras money welcome to Catherine
part 5 I love this game so much and I'm
so happy to be sharing it with you today
we just passed the first stage of level
4 I in case you don't know what the
is going on where this pajama man stuck
in this nightmare with a bunch of
falling blocks and then we're kind of
stuck in a nightmare in real life as
well but let's talk through this sheep
with the police at oh man I forgot to
talk to him it was at the bar I saw you
but whenever taun you look like a sheep
it's kind of weird trying to recognize a
sheep
oh I'm surprised you were able to climb
anything at all to be honest I like I'm
the only one with a pillow so
this guy was poked this is our friend or
he knows us I feel bad for him that way
what an let's stay with the
away from him they're gonna teach me
teach me sent back to explain okay
please do because
can't move those how do you do it then
Oh what how the did you do that
where your surroundings when you can
easily hang from blocks to reach your
destiny it's a beginner level skill but
don't forget it when faced with a
challenging situation that would make
sense I'm sorry if these are a bit
boring to go today I just really wanted
to know how to properly play the game so
if we make it out right here we get
that's a fair point
thank you yeah why not sure we don't
start off with the technique I came up
with to explain that cut out
grab one block after another
and move it towards your destination to
provide a punch it's important to
recognize which blocks and allow passage
again
I'll me I'm never gonna use that
and that looks like complicated alright
let's talk to this guy man let's get
going I didn't see yesterday's yeah
exactly
why are you worrying about other people
save your own ass and get out of here
fantastic alright well let's just answer
the question that's always kind of
awkward this is when you gonna lose your
dates based on appearance or personality
I wanna say mind but I know that will
make me give like the good option but
technically agree I'll have to pick me
yeah
damn it should I just commit to being
evil it seems kind of weird I kind of
just want to play how I want to play but
dammit he's too bad you're the one who
tried to take someone else's future
first think whose future are you about
to steal away you trying to say yeah
what does that mean every time we talk
to that we got a new info or some
oh man
okay let's see what other people answer
both said mine I mean if you're gonna
hang out with someone you go for who you
enjoy hanging out with regardless if
it's a date or not I think that would
like obviously I think looks are just
there as a first kind of you you notice
someone first but then can't fall in
love with someone who look this is the
final area for tonight deep face is in
your path for maybe you can take all and
take it that's outside stuff
second floor bros amazing I'm so bad at
this oh god not another
is that supposed to be our child what
the the child fantastic just what I
needed in my life thank you so out
of that baby black babe
oh god what am i doing I need a climb oh
god the piece of baby's
coming
oh god what do I do now please don't
call me daddy
go down look at that like a
Pro check fine
goddamn these bosses are so hard I'm
doing amazing we're doing amazing ryse
okay here sit
what is that an item it what does
that do daddy
stop shooting me daddy's very upset
let's go over here looks better
oh my god off
okay this Manville seems a lot easier
maybe not
I hear the bells bros I can hear the
Bears bris can that baby just
die oh my god what the that
I just saying I mean the cute little
demon thing I love it so much
oh god what am i doing don't up now
oh I need to get over there I can
use the spider climb
let's temp I taught me spider climbing
yeah yeah so genuinely good you he
disgusting love
alright alright alright alright
it's good yeah we kill that baby yeah
baby
hahaha great escape you survived
oh yeah Buress I know I shouldn't
be happy because I'm playing uneasy but
we got a silver price baby baby should
something maybe okay
well loading screen let's see me more
awkward wake up in the morning feeling
like
birthday Vincent's room and a faint
memory here are you okay did you drink
too much last night I think I drink too
much every day how does she know that we
don't remember you're acting weird weird
does she have a Zelda reference t-shirt
with you it's like the important parts
are missing I remember them
what should I do
just tell her no I can't wanna find out
like this
oh that's mine that's my pubes
you know hair grows on your body it's
good luck really
yeah rolling it out
it's just fell out by itself good thing
too it's bad luck if you pull it out
yourself you know oh really it's not
from another girl is it Vincent
no why would you say that you know
because if it is I'm going to die right
here hey hey hey hey knock it off with
all the dying stuff okay then I'll kill
you
oh I die or I kill you which would be
better
fine I'll give you five seconds if you
don't answer me I'll kill you okay
Vincent you're a coward seriously scary
like this she's gonna pull a knife on me
one day or something is no one-day
relationship Vincent you need to make
your mind Evan it doesn't matter
but from now on if you ever cheat on me
I'll be angry okay yeah
that's weird
what's with the door why does it always
pan out to the door no I definitely
don't leave definitely don't have to get
oh wait could she enter the heart attack
moment what the heck was this blocked
unchain this door yeah sure but hold on
a second
that it is my landlady she was trying to
open the door landlady gee I forgot to
pay my rent last month is the bathroom
what is this keep it down huh is here
huh really not the best time for you to
be why is he I should at least say hello
he gets real grumpy if you wake him up
he's sleeping in the back well if you
really think it would he's awake sorry
really sorry I just wanted to protect
you from the smell huh
he really smells you know and he was
drinking last night
oh really yeah I'm glad I got you out in
time
whew hey we're not that close but he
kind of forced his way in while he was
drunk oh well he is your boss huh
yeah he is
you just seemed really stressed so I
came to see how you were doing it thank
you
I have to work you know complaints more
I got you something from the new shop it
opened up oh yeah
I'll see you later Owen I am pregnant
I just wanted you to know seriously
was that why you really came here I need
to make up my mind quick you don't know
how that makes me feel seriously
see ya through the hall oh my god
laboratory Edward seriously though you
can't keep going like that
look at those look at those I can't let
her tempt me really rude I gotta do
something quick done sorry
you're late did you see the movie where
the guy was you know alright alright
alright thinking this can't go on any
longer I have to tell her to stop
picture did you not to leave that
picture back at Kappa heaven you still
doing the two-timing tango don't say it
like that it wasn't on purpose she is
pregnant you gotta bite the bullet yeah
you're only saying that cuz it's not you
hey man
variety is the spice of life to enjoy
just like the wasabi coated sushi they
serve
maybe Catherine would be happier as a
single mom and she would be with you
what are you drunk no she wouldn't want
that but what exactly do you want here
my mind and my heart don't exactly agree
you've got to be even more careful
you're caught you can't call it an
accident anymore I know I know
the old guy next door to make the book
it's supposed to be good for your
circulation
oh hey like ghosts you going to the bar
tonight maybe you have to pass today
not over time but I guess all you can do
is drink and forget huh pretty much we
are pretty bros gotta say it
there's no doubt about it is the
only thing we are definitely I really
owned at the bar today
there's the cop that I wanted to talk to
you last time we can drink
there's no reason how do we keep
ending up cheatin this is not cheating
anymore this is like Orlando hey
don't be too hard on yourself bro
marriage isn't all bad it's nice to be
able to have someone special to spend
the rest of your life with what is this
hi Vincent
I'm sending you a special picture trying
to act surprised if you're opening it at
work or something just thinking of your
reaction when you see it is making me
laugh didn't she send us that picture
ready
yeah I keep cheating why can't I just
tell her I have a girlfriend yeah why
here's some trivia for you as you seem
to have finished your class come on did
you know the United States outlawed
alcohol between 1920 really 3 it is said
that this very prohibition paved a way
for the cocktail culture to bloom really
alcohol made in secret tended to taste
terrible
so people began mixing it with anything
and everything to make it more enjoyable
watch these are the roots of the modern
cocktail the more you stamp on a weed
the more it drives fantastic all right
let's get some I don't know do I have to
get another one it's pretty rare for you
to be here by yourself maybe I'll have a
drink oh hey don't you work here do your
job you sure know how to choose a place
to work
so she's not gonna sit down with us
should we look at the picture it
let's look at the picture we should talk
to them later yes it's awkward if you
don't space travel in the beginning much
more the trip will cost what's this
about marriage joking right
trip into space okay well let's look at
some snazzy pictures rather right all
right let's look at that send them
titties yeah we've seen them on them
well alright alright do you like cake I
saw an article in a magazine about the
best bakeries in the city it's kind of
embarrassing for a guy to eat everyone
alone so I thinking you might want to go
with me we're here that plays with a
great view I was telling you about
yesterday if you want to go please tell
me what days you're available
Tobias I can't reply to it what's the
point
if your last text hey sorry man the
text I just sent was for Erica just
pretend you never saw it I'm not gonna
be at the bar tonight I have to buy
something at them Johnny will be from
there so be sure to talk to him and
don't tell Erica that I'm buying
anything or land ok Moretti's alright we
saw some titties we didn't feed hello
you can't pee at a toilet you can
literally just watch case all right
let's talk I kept saying that I should
talk to the policeman so let's let's
just do that
you're gonna bother a cop on his break
you want to ask me about that incident
I'm not gonna be much help but it's men
around your age or dying so be really
careful you don't seem too interested
and no evidence has come up yet and I'm
on another case gotcha I'm Morgan if I
find anything out about this incident
will tell you so worried about the
strange rumors Wow
I don't really care about the rumors
sorry I don't have any information about
that incident I'll be on the job today
though so hopefully I'll have begin a
text our relations all right
I want to text Catherine so we can
change hopefully our stats a little bit
the only way to do that is to talk to
people should we sit I don't have any
problems for you to talk about boss is
the rest of your group working tonight
some days our schedules don't meet up
that's all it's a bit lonely without
them he's speaking of which the biggest
reason men start thinking about marriage
is loneliness marriage is a state where
two people can't stand living together
and can't stand living apart to NAV a
rotation from a certain someone if you
stay in an apartment by yourself long
enough you tend to start thinking really
but when it comes down to actually
getting married throw back some liquor
and hit the hay to get the whole of the
sky on the ground you have to laugh
though that rumor about strange
nightmares does worry me a bit why don't
you ask around everyone here seems to be
talk yeah everyone Lily text Catherine
hey how's it goin Vincent what are you
doing tonight I'm drinking with friends
we'll talk later I'm still at work why
do you care
such an reply let's to go with
that okay see that's this one I wanted
so I guess we can keep going
I never looked at the TV interesting
okay time to go home and start another
nightmare great times you should go home
and get some rest
I know oh yeah about my bill yeah put it
on your tab right I know I know anyway
just make sure you get home safely okay
with all the rumors and bad news going
around you worry too much Eric I'll be
fine
see you soon all right all right all
right
and so another nightmare begins new
fifth day Vince's room a little earlier
than usual 20 minutes later we are
asleep and the first fifth nightmare
damn it there's only eight days in this
game
I want this date to go on forever I
think this one is gonna be hard
we'll see look at that
getting to the top quadrangle first
floor okay
be careful thank you strange man with a
big voice I love you let's do one of
these the first stage and then I'll
probably do it soon I think I think
falling is so if I go right now I'm
gonna slide off if I understand
correctly that's enter like that
I can go like this then I get that right
I don't know we'll see if it go left now
yeah okay I understand there we go it's
a little weird but we can manage Bros
but that is that made on well
you're and that's how it done
bris
all right Iran Iran
I won't slide off here
spider trick all right all right Iraq oh
god damn it I missed a pillow
some of the music okay now we can create
a block fan-fucking-tastic why did I do
that love is over
this looks complicated
the that I just do there you go
beautiful we did it and let's grab it
awesome Wow all right for us gonna have
to end that if I so there oh man I love
this game so much it's so much fun to
play with you bros thank you for
watching now it's a great time to leave
a like share this video with all your
family and friends and I'll see you in
the next one as always stay awesome bros